récession économique peuvent avoir de
lourds impacts sur la santé mentale de
la population et c'est ce que souligne
deloitte canada dans un rapport qui a
été publié aujourd'hui alors comment les
entreprises les gouvernements
peuvent-ils se préparer pour affronter
cet enjeu je discute avec l'auteur du
rapport mathieu laberge qui directeur
principal services conseils en économie
chez deloitte canada bonjour monsieur
laberge oro premièrement il ne faut pas
se mettre la tête dans le sable il y
aura des conséquences néfastes des
effets psychologiques sur les gens avec
cette pandémie
absolument la combinaison l'isolation de
ce printemps avec la récession actuelle
va avoir des impacts qui pourrait être
important pourquoi se le cacher on parle
ici de jusqu'à 3% de peluches de visite
à 3 3 fois plus de visites pardon de
chez eux professer la santé mentale 20%
plus de prescription d'antidépresseurs
on parle ici d'un demi million à la
grandeur du pays
plus discret d'entreprise assez
significatif et donc plus de visites
chez le psychologue alors on pourrait
tout dans une détresse psychologique est
plus importante
qu'est ce qui va ce soir également au
dessus de votre apport est ce qu on note
aussi c'est que le groupe qui est le
plus vulnérable à ses effets la les
aguerrir impact humain de la coved 19
c'est l'effet est particulièrement les
mères monoparentales pourquoi tous mes
monoparentales parce que travaille
davantage rue dans les services
notamment est en fait oui il ya une
combinaison de facteurs incluent là
c'est la composition des pertes
d'emplois qui est concentrée dans les
registres des services dont qui touche
bastad en plus de femmes par exemple
quand on compère du milieu 2009
il ya le fait climat monoparentales un
taux d'incidence du bord revenus qui
plus élevé que l'ensemble de la
population et c'est le deuxième groupe
après les personnes âgées qui est le
plus haut taux d'incidence ayant aussi
le fait que les femmes en général dans
les sondages de statistique canada
rapporte en général proportions plus de
conditions sentimentale que les hommes
mais aussi que leurs besoins sont moins
bien rencontrer est ce qu'on pourrait
dire que la pandémie fragilise encore
davantage du groupe qui était déjà
fragilisée absolument c'est exactement
ce qui ressort de notre rapport des gens
qui étaient dans une situation vue
érable avant la part des ministres
trouve dans une situation qu'il est
encore plus net avec quel genre de
répercussion on peut s'attendre à voir
lorsqu'une population n'est pas en bonne
santé mentale ce qu'on prévoit donc une
baisse on l'a vu donc il ya des effets
évidemment donc humain détresse
psychologique
est ce qu'on peut voir aussi donc une
baisse de l'activité économique
absolument je pense que ce qui est
important de mentionner sait aussi que
les impacts humains ça dépasse la
question de santé mentale
ce que pour qu'on s'est concentré sur la
santé mentale c'est que les données sont
disponibles présentement mais ça peut
avoir aussi des impacts sur les
résultats scolaires sur la persévérance
scolaire sur les crimes
l'abus de substances également et quand
on regarde seul impact pour l'économie
dit multiples penser à l'étudiant par
seconde à qui décide de retourner
universités au cgem et ses disciples on
va le suivre pour les villes doivent ont
un impact sur sa capacité à réaliser son
plein potentiel comme comme travailleur
par exemple quand on parle aux des
conditions de santé mentale mais il ya
un impact sur la productivité
une baraque sur les heures travaillées
mais aussi à la base un pas qui tu une
seconde libération dans laquelle est
facile d'évoluer
les gens qui étaient déjà vulnérables se
retrouvent encore plus est finie et on
peut apprendre d'autres crises
celle notamment on se rappelle tous les
incendies à fortes mais que oui quel
genre d'impact on avait vu là bas
absolument et non scénarios sont
essentiellement basées sur ce qu'on
avait du jury et je pense que ce qu'il
très troublant qui ressort de l'étude
c'est que fort prix quatre ans après
instant 2016 dont les quatre ans plus
tard et non seulement les niveaux de
besoins de santé mentale on peut ne sont
pas revenus à la normale mais lyon il
montre aucun signe de normalisation sont
encore aussi lui caire quelques semaines
marcatraz après il n'y a pas eu de
demande d'amélioration c'est ce que vous
avez vu absolument
c'est ce qui ressort des données pour
les diagnostics de santé mentale les
prescriptions
quand on regarde aussi les récessions
passées l'instar de chômage de long
terme donc plus d'un an prend jusqu'à 5
ans cela remet les oies commencé à se
normaliser après la fin d'une récession
alors ses impacts humains ils sont avec
nous devons arriver ils sont avec nous
pour longtemps
crise financière parce qu'on se rappelle
tous également donc la crise financière
de 2008
on avait remarqué le même genre d'impact
également absolument c'est ce qu'on
remarque dans le cas des récessions des
crises financières mais ce qui est
particulièrement important
cette fois ci c'était aussi une
combinaison de d'événements désastreux
ou de désastres naturels où il ya eu une
isolation d'encaisser une évacuation
dans notre cas c'est une isolation mais
si ça a un impact en plus c'est bon on
va regarder mes rêves à l'avenir quelles
sont les solutions qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire donc pour prévenir des dommages
des dommages humains de cette crise là
parce que c'est le message d'espoir du
rapport on s'est faits serait un bon
plat des citrons le mettra essayons d'en
transformer au moins une personne
citronnade je pense que il a pas dû nous
a surpris
si la récession nous a déstabilisés
aucune raison qu'on va contenir la crise
d impact humain qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour les gouvernements ça veut
dire maximiser l'utilisation des réseaux
qui sont déjà en place comme les
garderies les écoles ou les batteries
les personnes qui ont vendu pas moi je
suis toujours quand on a accès à un
enfant drax un parent tuer tout
l'écosystème une familiale à tous et les
gens qui l'entourent il faut être
capable d'identifier ceux qui ont besoin
de support et ensuite de les référer
vers les ressources appropriées que ce
soit dans le secteur public la non dans
le secteur privé
parfois il y en a même qui sont à but
non lucratif très bon coup et si
celle-ci fournisseurs de services parce
que ce que ça nous a démontré ce qui est
une opportunité pour migrer une partie
des services sur dp fonction digital et
donc davantage d'innovation de temps à
20 secondes ou suis donc du service
public également que seront forts pour
fera front tu es finalement cette
crise-là envers second acte ils mac
seront fox confronté aussi en fait c'est
très rapidement pour les emplois
d'ouvrir le dialogue avec trois employés
sur la flexibilité le niveau de support
dont ils ont besoin pour voir ce serait
intégrée à l'emploi très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur laberge avons été avec
nous merci et bonne soirée